un à l'appel des autorités locales les
habitants des îles grecques vont jusqu'à
l'affrontement avec la police anti
émeute nationale objectif empêcher la
construction de nouveaux camps d'accueil
pour demandeurs d'asile et réfugiés
les installations actuelles surpeuplée
sont invivables convives comme des
animaux à moriat et ils veulent partir
ils veulent partir et trouver quelque
chose de mieux
c'est ce que nous voulons ce alors nous
nous battons pour eux et pour nous le
gouvernement devrait aller se noyer ce
n'est pas une situation acceptable
nos ils sont comme une zone de guerre je
ne dis pas que les immigrés clandestins
ne sont pas les êtres humains ce sont
des êtres humains mais nous ne voulons
pas de prison ferme et dans ces régions
proches de la frontière turque cela fait
des années qu'on se plaint de la
présence d'étrangers
ce que demandent ces manifestants et
grévistes drapeaux grecs à bout de bras
que les demandeurs d'asile soit prise en
charge en grèce continentale pour être
renvoyé le plus vite possible
hors du pays selon l' agence des nations
unies pour les réfugiés
avec près de 60000 arrivé en 2019 soit
le double de l'année précédente
les îles grecques sont le principal
point d'entrée de l'immigration
clandestine dans l'union européenne
[Musique]